This is a classic like, okay, I say, can I, no I'm, Can I just say, what, okay, okay, oh, can I, can I just say, okay, so. All I'm trying to say, so I wanted to say yeah. Okay, okay, just one minute. Can I say, one word, can I say, can I say one word, can I say, do you want to listen to me? Listen. All I'm saying.
这是一个经典的，好吧，我说，我可以，不，我，我能说吗，什么，好吧，好吧，哦，我可以，我能说吗，好吧，所以。我只是想说，所以我本来想说，是的。好吧，好吧，就一分钟。我能说吗，一个词，我能说吗，我能说一个词吗，我能说吗，你想听我说吗？听着。我只是想说。
It's all going to be smartless. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
这一切都将是Smartless。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Guys, what do they call that like a red letter day or date? What is it called? Like when it's a good thing happened? Okay, go ahead.
Smart。Smart。Smart。伙计们，他们管那个叫什么，红字日还是红字日期？那叫什么？就是当一件好事发生的时候？好吧，你继续。
Yeah, what does that mean red letter day? Sean, first of all. Who's got a Wi-Fi signal? Yeah. Somebody can Google that? Sean, what are you thinking? What are you thinking that why is this a great day? What's going on?
是的，红字日是什么意思？肖恩，首先。谁有Wi-Fi信号？是的。有人能谷歌一下吗？肖恩，你在想什么？你觉得为什么这是伟大的一天？发生了什么事？
Well, because Ricky, who's sitting right next to me, his scab, remember that huge, what's it called? Tumor or thing that he had? Oh, this is, welcome back to Remembering Scabs. I'm your host. Yeah. And for the listener, Ricky is your best friend, your buddy.
嗯，因为瑞奇，就坐在我旁边，他的痂，还记得那个巨大的，叫什么来着？肿瘤还是什么东西？哦，这是，欢迎回到《记住痂》。我是你们的主持人。是的。对于听众来说，瑞奇是你最好的朋友，你的哥们。
Yeah. Your buddy's got a terrible case of herpes constantly, right? No, he had that big, what's it called? Like tumor, like benign tumor. Anyway, so he got it gouged out. It was massive. And now it's scabbed and the scabs started falling off.
是的。你的哥们一直有严重的疱疹，对吧？不，他有那个大的，叫什么来着？像肿瘤，良性肿瘤。总之，他把它挖出来了。那东西很大。现在它结痂了，痂开始脱落了。
And that's when my mouth starts to water. Like, you ever watch those videos with the earwax and stuff, scabs for you? No, no, we don't watch any videos about earwax. Do you? Yeah. Or like the doctor, the pimple popper thing? Yeah, pimple popper.
然后我的口水就开始流了。就像，你看过那些关于耳垢之类的视频吗，痂对你来说？不，不，我们不看任何关于耳垢的视频。你看吗？是的。或者像医生，挤痘痘的那种？是的，挤痘痘。
I know, it's incredible. I think it's like, it's so sad. Oh, that's a whole thing. Have you not seen those, Jay? What are you talking about? There's a show. Doesn't she have a show on like learning channel or something called Dr. Pimple Popper?
我知道，这太不可思议了。我觉得这太，太悲哀了。哦，那是一整件事。你没看过那些吗，杰？你在说什么？有个节目。她不是在学习频道还是什么地方有个节目叫《挤痘医生》吗？
Dr. Pimple Popper. And it's this dermatologist and she goes in, she has people who have like extreme growths and acne and cysts and shit. And she like gets rid of them and extracts them. It's fascinating. Yeah, yeah. It's so great.
《挤痘医生》。就是这个皮肤科医生，她进去，她有那些长了极端赘生物、痤疮和囊肿之类的家伙。她把它们除掉并取出来。这太迷人了。是的，是的。太棒了。
So sorry, listener. We're gonna be a bit. Where is this? On the television side. On the learning channel. Yeah, she has a whole thing. And if you look online, somebody told me about it. This is a television show with commercials and stuff.
抱歉，听众朋友们。我们要稍微……这是在哪？在电视上。在学习频道。是的，她有一整套节目。如果你上网查，有人告诉过我。这是一个有广告之类的电视节目。
Oh yeah. Yeah, well you can YouTube. And you can YouTube it. You would be blown away and the millions of views that they get, I mean. And the draw is just come and watch all the pus come out. That's why you're tuning in. I think so.
哦，是的。是的，嗯，你可以上YouTube。你可以上YouTube看。你会大吃一惊，他们获得的数百万次观看量，我的意思是。吸引力就是来看脓液流出来。这就是你收看的原因。我想是这样。
That's right. I think that it's a whole community of people who just fucking are obsessed with it. I love that. And also, but the earwax, like when people go in and get like mounds of earwax out of somebody's ear. Stop talking to me like I know what you're talking about. Well, it's just like.
没错。我认为这是一群完全沉迷于此的人。我喜欢这个。而且，还有耳垢，就像人们进去从某人的耳朵里弄出成堆的耳垢。别再跟我说话了，好像我知道你在说什么一样。嗯，这就像。
It's like when people talk about taking freeways in certain places and they're like, and then we were on the 605, you know where it goes into them. And like, no, I don't, man. I don't fucking know where that is. So Sean, there is a. Oh, the earwax.
就像人们谈论在某些地方走高速公路，他们说，然后我们在605号公路上，你知道它通往他们那里。然后就像，不，我不知道，伙计。我他妈不知道那在哪里。所以肖恩，有一个。哦，耳垢。
Is a common thing where earwax. Yeah, well you can. You show about that too. No, there's not a show, but you can like YouTube videos of like people going in and taking earwax out like doctors and stuff. Have you ever had, I had to have some removed. I went to the doctor once, this is 10 years ago,
是一件常见的事情，耳垢。是的，嗯，你可以。你也有关于那个的节目。不，没有节目，但你可以像YouTube视频那样，看人们进去清理耳垢，比如医生之类的。你有没有过，我不得不去清理一些。我十年前去看过医生，
and they go, oh, you should go downstairs and see ENT. You've got quite a lot of buildup in your ear. True story. Not shocking, by the way. And I go in, how do you mean? Well, just listen, if you could see Will right now. I mean, he's just, no one needs to see him before noon on any day.
他们说，哦，你应该下楼去看看耳鼻喉科。你的耳朵里积聚了很多东西。真实故事。顺便说一句，这并不令人震惊。我进去了，你是什么意思？嗯，听着，如果你现在能看到威尔就好了。我的意思是，他只是，没人需要在中午之前看到他。
Listen, I keep it very tight as you know. And so I go in in there and they go, yeah, and the guy takes it out. I kept it in a jar. Booping like a little container, because it was so. I need to see that. Do you still have it? Oh God.
听着，如你所知，我保持得很紧凑。所以我进去了，他们说，是的，那个人把它取出来了。我把它放在一个罐子里。像一个小容器，因为它太……我需要看看那个。你还有吗？哦，天哪。
I sold it. Someone woke up this little kitty cat. I sold it. Oh, what's that, Sean? You want to see that? Do you have the tumor from your herpetic friend? No, but I did, I had all herpetic. Did I use that right? Yeah, that is right, actually.
我把它卖了。有人吵醒了这只小猫咪。我把它卖了。哦，那是什么，肖恩？你想看那个？你有你那个疱疹朋友的肿瘤吗？不，但我确实，我有所有的疱疹。我用对词了吗？是的，那确实是对的。
I know you did. But yeah, as it fell off, my mouth started watering. I was like, oh, and then I picked some of it off. This is why you love dumplings from Chin Chin, right? That's exactly right. You just cut it open and it oozes out. Oh God, don't make a stone-truck person with the food. This is sort of like a little pod with meat on the inside.
我知道你用了。但是是的，当它掉下来的时候，我的口水就开始流了。我就像，哦，然后我抠掉了一些。这就是你喜欢秦秦饺子的原因，对吧？完全正确。你把它切开，它就流出来了。哦，天哪，别让一个石头人谈论食物。这有点像里面有肉的小包子。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Just kind of open and watch it all come out. I feel bad for our guests. They've had to listen to potentially our most disgusting intro to the show ever. It better not be a classy person. Well, put it this way. I feel good about it because I feel like this person and I,
是的，是的，是的。只是切开看着它流出来。我为我们的嘉宾感到难过。他们不得不听我们节目有史以来最恶心的开场白。最好不是一个有档次的人。嗯，这么说吧。我对此感觉很好，因为我觉得这个人和我，
we share this in common in that we both have Canadian origins. Oh, here we go. I don't think that he grew up in Canada, but I know that he is a card-carrying Canadian. His parents are Canadian. So I think that he's probably got a pretty loose sense of humor about stuff like that
我们有共同点，因为我们都有加拿大血统。哦，开始了。我不认为他在加拿大长大，但我知道他是一个持证的加拿大人。他的父母是加拿大人。所以我认为他可能对这类事情有相当宽松的幽默感，
and can be in pretty easy going. You know how we are up there, eh? Oh, sure. Yeah, so you can talk about the gross stuff and we're like, oh fuck, that's pretty gross there, bud. But all right, you know, not gonna get too bogged down by it. But this guy's had,
而且可以相当随和。你知道我们在上面是怎么样的，对吧？哦，当然。是的，所以你可以谈论恶心的东西，我们会说，哦，该死，那挺恶心的，伙计。但是好吧，你知道，不会被它困住。但这家伙有，
he's lived here and he's had so much success here. And he started making films. You know, it's funny, he had two films. His first two films opened within, I think within maybe the same year, over 30 years ago. One was a very much a sort of a comedy. The other one was much more dramatic. The dramatic film that he was in
他住在这里，他在这里取得了巨大的成功。他开始拍电影。你知道，很有趣，他有两部电影。他的前两部电影上映时间，我想可能在同一年，30多年前。一部是非常典型的喜剧。另一部则戏剧性得多。他参演的那部剧情片
launched the careers of many young men, including Matt Damon, Chris O'Donnell, Ben Affleck, had a lot of young guns in this film. He then went on to make just film after film after film. He was in a huge blockbuster franchise films. He was in really cool, interesting indie films. And then for a moment, it felt like, it almost felt like I wasn't,
开启了许多年轻人的职业生涯，包括马特·达蒙、克里斯·奥唐纳、本·阿弗莱克，这部电影里有很多年轻气盛的演员。他后来又拍了一部又一部电影。他参演了巨大的大片系列电影。他参演了非常酷、有趣的独立电影。然后有一阵子，感觉就像，几乎感觉我不是，
we weren't seeing him in as many films for a minute. We're gonna get into that part of his life. Sure will. But then he came back bigger than ever. Wait, if this is who I think it is. Someone say, as big as a whale, guys, it's none other than Brendan Fraser. No way! Good Lord!
我们有一阵子没看到他拍那么多电影了。我们要深入了解他生命中的那一部分。当然会。但他回来时比以往任何时候都更强大。等等，如果这是我想的那个人。有人说，像鲸鱼一样大，伙计们，他不是别人，正是布兰登·费舍。不会吧！天哪！
Hi guys. Hi! Brendan Fraser! Well, what an honor, very pleasure. You are a busy man right now, huh? Yes, but not too busy. You're up early doing a podcast with us. It's a guy, nothing could be busier. Happy to drop in.
你们好。嗨！布兰登·费舍！哇，真是荣幸，非常高兴。你现在是个大忙人，对吧？是的，但没那么忙。你起得这么早来和我们做播客。伙计，没有什么比这更忙的了。很高兴能来。
Are you in LA right now? No, no, I'm in New York. I live in an update in New York. Oh, so it's not so early. No, no. Brendan Fraser joining us from upstate New York. Dude, what an honor and pleasure to meet you. And it just, I gotta say,
你现在在洛杉矶吗？不，不，我在纽约。我住在纽约北部。哦，所以没那么早。不，不。布兰登·费舍从纽约北部加入我们。伙计，见到你真是荣幸和高兴。我不得不说，
it's one of those great stories because there aren't often a lot of, there are a lot of feel bad stories around and you gotta kind of look for the feel good stories and yours certainly is a feel good story in watching you kind of all of a sudden just, I'm sure, and you can tell us. Everybody's like, wow, it's even me saying,
这是一个伟大的故事，因为通常没有很多，周围有很多让人感觉糟糕的故事，你得去寻找那些让人感觉良好的故事，你的故事当然是一个让人感觉良好的故事，看着你突然之间，我相信，你可以告诉我们。每个人都像，哇，甚至连我也在说，
oh, you've had this sort of resurgence or this comeback and you're kind of, tell me what that experience is like because do you feel like, hey, motherfuckers, I've been here the whole time? Well, I guess that's the epistleistic question. Did I leave or did it leave me? I just only know as I'm here now.
哦，你经历了这种复苏或回归，你有点，告诉我那种经历是什么样的，因为你是否觉得，嘿，混蛋们，我一直都在这里？嗯，我想那是那个形而上学的问题。是我离开了，还是它离开了我？我只知道我现在在这里。
And I'm happy to be. And you probably were working, I mean, I've gone through a period that was less active than periods before or periods after and but all that was was that, well, I was a working actor, I was still paying my bills, I just wasn't in vehicles that got a hold and a lot of notoriety and I was just lucky
我很高兴能在这里。你可能一直在工作，我的意思是，我经历过一段比之前或之后都不那么活跃的时期，但那只是，嗯，我是一个职业演员，我还在付账单，我只是没有参与那些获得关注和很多名气的项目，我只是很幸运，
that I was in some before and in some afterwards but always kind of working. Was that what the sort of perceived valley was? I've always kept busy, that's for sure. I mean, I don't think there was a year when I didn't have something to do. Yeah, exactly, yeah. Just the stuff was so huge before and huge after.
我之前参与过一些，之后也参与过一些，但一直都在工作。这就是所谓的感知低谷吗？我一直很忙，那是肯定的。我的意思是，我不认为有哪一年我没有事情做。是的，完全正确，是的。只是之前的东西太巨大了，之后也太巨大了。
Yeah, there was a real proliferation when I came out of the gate pretty early and I think I was even in competition with myself on some weekends, you know, in the genius of release dates. Wow. Where is that guy? Right. Oh, it's me. Oh, so busy.
是的，当我刚出道时，确实有真正的激增，我想我甚至在某些周末与自己竞争，你知道，在发行日期的天才安排下。哇。那个人在哪里？对。哦，是我。哦，太忙了。
So how was that? Did you enjoy that level of busyness and notoriety and like another version of Brendan that was someone other than who you had grown up being, you know, like the public's version? I guess I kind of had blinders on. I didn't really pay that much attention to the result of what I was doing.
那么感觉如何？你享受那种忙碌和名气的程度，以及另一个版本的布兰登，那个不是你从小长大的那个人，你知道，比如公众版本？我想我有点戴着眼罩。我并没有真正关注我所做事情的结果。
So much as I was doing what I was doing to keep busy. I guess the answer is I was never a big party guy and never went out. I stayed away from, you know, glitzy events and that kind of thing. I was like, I had to be at work in the morning and on top of that, I'm also very, very bored. You would have seen Jason
与其说我是在做我正在做的事情来保持忙碌。我想答案是我从来不是一个喜欢聚会的人，也从来不出门。我远离那些，你知道，浮华的活动之类的东西。我就像，我早上必须去工作，而且除此之外，我也非常，非常无聊。你会看到杰森
in a lot of those glitzy events had you gone. Yeah, I would have been a lot of high fives coming from me. Oh, dude. So you didn't miss much anyway, Brendan. So I don't think I did either, but you know, I was too busy trying to stay, keep my head in the game for whatever I had. I was up to you.
如果你去了，会在很多那些浮华的活动中看到他。是的，我会从我这里得到很多击掌。哦，伙计。所以你反正也没错过什么，布兰登。所以我认为我也没有，但你知道，我太忙于试图保持，让我的头脑专注于我所拥有的任何事情。我当时取决于你。
I should have hung out with you. Yeah, I once ran into you, Brendan, like, is that a, I don't know. I think it was an event honoring Steve Martin, maybe? Or, oh, can't remember where it was. It was an event and I just, it was, I just couldn't, I couldn't believe I was meeting. I was like, oh my God, it's Brendan Fraser.
我本应该和你一起出去玩的。是的，我曾经遇到过你，布兰登，就像，那是，我不知道。我想那是一个纪念史蒂夫·马丁的活动，也许？或者，哦，记不起在哪里了。那是一个活动，我只是，我只是不能，我简直不敢相信我正在见面。我就像，哦，天哪，是布兰登·费舍。
And you were the nicest Saturday night life. No, no, it was, it was in town here in Los Angeles. And you were just so nice. And we just hung out briefly for two seconds backstage, chatting and clearly. He's got no memory of this show. Yeah, really. He's got no memory of this show.
你是最棒的周六夜现场。不，不，它，它就在这里洛杉矶城里。你真是太好了。我们在后台简短地聊了两秒钟，很明显。他对这个节目没有记忆。是的，真的。他对这个节目没有记忆。
It didn't make quite an impact as you did on me. I should tell you also, I was dropped on my head a lot in my career. Sure. Wow. I had you showing up with that tumor in a jar, Sean. You wouldn't have forgotten that. Yeah, that's true.
它没有像你对我那样产生那么大的影响。我还应该告诉你，我的职业生涯中头部被摔了很多次。当然。哇。肖恩，你带着那个罐子里的肿瘤出现。你不会忘记那个的。是的，那是真的。
Yeah, that's what that really means. So Brendan, let's go way back a little bit. So as I mentioned that, what sort of, what's your connection to Canada? Your parents are Canadian. Did you spend any time there? Did you grow up there at all? I was born in the U.S.
是的，那才是它真正的意思。所以布兰登，让我们稍微回顾一下。正如我提到的，你和加拿大有什么联系？你的父母是加拿大人。你在那里待过吗？你在那里长大吗？我出生在美国。
So I'm a Canadian born abroad. Dual heritage. But Canada definitely claims me as local boy done good. Which part of Canada? Ottawa, Ontario, Toronto. My father, I have a family in Vancouver, in BC. Oh, all over the place. My father hails from the Maritimes
所以我是一个在国外出生的加拿大人。双重血统。但加拿大绝对声称我是当地的好孩子。加拿大的哪个部分？渥太华，安大略，多伦多。我父亲，我在温哥华，在BC省有家人。哦，到处都是。我父亲来自海洋省份，
and my mom was a girl in Saskatoon, Saskatchewan. Canadian cowboy. Wait a second, hang on one second. Your dad's from the Maritimes. What part of the Maritimes do you know exactly? Is he behind Nova Scotia? From Nova Scotia, wait till Eli hears about this. Our buddy Eli, who, you know,
我妈妈是萨斯喀彻温省萨斯卡通的女孩。加拿大牛仔。等等，等一下。你爸爸来自海洋省份。你知道具体是海洋省份的哪个部分吗？是在新斯科舍省后面吗？来自新斯科舍省，等伊莱听到这个。我们的哥们伊莱，你知道，
right, he just stopped combing somebody's hair. Mid brush. He's this, what? Why, is that where he's from? He's from Halifax, Nova Scotia. When he finds out that Brendan's dad is from Nova Scotia, he's gonna lose it. You know, they'll say, is that right?
对，他刚停止给某人梳头。梳到一半。他是这个，什么？为什么，那是他来自的地方吗？他来自新斯科舍省哈利法克斯。当他发现布兰登的爸爸来自新斯科舍省时，他会疯掉的。你知道，他们会说，那是真的吗？
Oh, he's not right. Fuck, you know what? I think he'll always do that. Who's your father's father? Yeah, who is he? Oh, yeah. Everyone knows everyone. Yeah, I seen him down there.
哦，他不正确。该死，你知道吗？我想他总是会那样做。你父亲的父亲是谁？是的，他是谁？哦，是的。每个人都认识每个人。是的，我在那里见过他。
He works at the post office with the other guy who works at the post office. Yeah, yeah. So isn't Maritime like a nautical term? Nice. The islands, yeah. And the town's called Maritime. No, the area is called the Maritimes.
他在邮局和另一个在邮局工作的人一起工作。是的，是的。那么海洋省份不是一个航海术语吗？不错。岛屿，是的。那个镇叫海洋省份。不，那个地区叫海洋省份。
No, it's not M-A-R-Y, second word, T-R-M-E. Yeah. Oh, now it's Maritime. During the week, I worked for my boss, but come Friday, it's Maritime. That's M-E-R-R-Y. Yeah. Christmas, that's Maritime.
不，它不是M-A-R-Y，第二个词，T-R-M-E。是的。哦，现在是Maritime。周一到周五，我为老板工作，但到了周五，就是Maritime。那是M-E-R-R-Y。是的。圣诞节，那是Maritime。
So, Sean, oh, for fuck's sake. I apologize, Brendan. Sean, you know that your college just lost their accreditation, you know that, right? They've just been completely, they've just been stripped of everything. So, Brendan.
所以，肖恩，哦，看在上帝的份上。我道歉，布兰登。肖恩，你知道你的大学刚刚失去了认证，你知道吗？他们刚刚被完全，他们刚刚被剥夺了一切。所以，布兰登。
So, Brendan, you're up there in Canada, you're freezing your nards off, and you're thinking, I wanna be on stage. Yeah, you move down to the States, and you go to high school in the States, yes? Something like you've done a bunch of research. I have. My father's work was with Tourism Canada,
所以，布兰登，你在加拿大，你冻得要死，你在想，我想在舞台上。是的，你搬到了美国，你在美国上高中，对吧？就像你做了一堆研究一样。我有。我父亲的工作是旅游加拿大，
which is a defunct branch of the government now, wherein his job was basically to sell Canada, so they were up. Sounds like spy work to me. Go ahead. I know, I can be a perfect cover. You put a half a beer in him, I bet you get a lot of stories.
那是政府现在的一个废弃部门，他的工作基本上是推销加拿大，所以他们当时在上面。听起来像间谍工作。你继续。我知道，我可以是一个完美的掩护。你给他喝半杯啤酒，我敢打赌你会得到很多故事。
I tried that, I seriously, dude, I did. I tried, he didn't say anything about it. You know, he's very, very boring that way. We traveled every three, four years, so there's many postings. So that's why they lived in the United States when I was born, and they moved around parts of Canada too. So, Ottawa, in the 70s, he was posted in Holland.
我试过了，我认真地，伙计，我试过了。我试过了，他什么也没说。你知道，他在这方面非常，非常无聊。我们每三四年旅行一次，所以有很多岗位。这就是为什么我出生时他们住在美国，他们也搬到了加拿大的各个地方。所以，渥太华，在70年代，他被派驻到荷兰。
We lived there for four years, and then Seattle, Washington. Think back, did you ever hear sirens consistently, the last sound you heard before you left places? Think back, yeah, think back. Because if you heard sirens, were you guys living in the middle of the night a lot? Yeah.
我们在那里住了四年，然后是华盛顿州西雅图。回想一下，你是否曾经持续听到警笛声，那是你离开这些地方之前听到的最后声音？回想一下，是的，回想一下。因为如果你听到了警笛声，你们是不是经常在半夜搬家？是的。
Were you hustled into vans? We'll side guard this, yeah. Well, I was just gonna say a lot of B.C. and Holland. There's also a real weed trail here, Brendan, that I don't think there is. Good, well, good. We're gonna crack this, Brendan. It started early.
你们是被匆忙赶进货车的吗？我们会侧面保护这个，是的。嗯，我只是想说很多BC省和荷兰。这里也有一条真正的杂草小径，布兰登，我不认为有。好，嗯，好。我们要破解这个，布兰登。它开始得很早。
So then, okay, so you're moving all around, and you decide, and you're drawn to acting to theater, what was that first engagement? I was going to high school in Toronto at Upper Canada College, and I wasn't a very good student at all. You were at UCC? Correct, yeah, guilty.
所以，好吧，所以你到处搬家，你决定，你被表演吸引，被戏剧吸引，那第一次接触是什么？我在多伦多的上加拿大书院上高中，我根本不是一个好学生。你在UCC？正确，是的，有罪。
Wow. Did you go to the same high school as Eric McCormick and Mike Myers and all those people? No. I don't know that. Okay, Sean. I think they went to, I wanna say North Toronto, I can't remember.
哇。你和埃里克·麦柯马克、迈克·梅尔斯以及所有那些人上的是同一所高中吗？不。我不知道那个。好吧，肖恩。我想他们去了，我想说是北多伦多，我不记得了。
I don't know. I don't know. Sorry, keep going. That was the 80s. That was me doing school. I was a bad student, and I was, I found- I was, wait, Brendan, how old a gentleman are you?
我不知道。我不知道。抱歉，继续。那是80年代。那是我在做学校。我是一个坏学生，我，我发现——我当时，等等，布兰登，你这位绅士多大了？
I'm 54. Okay, so we're around the same age. Yeah, how did you guys not bump into each other? I'm asking a question now, but I've never been this famous and unsolidated at the same time, so a lot doesn't make sense to me. Ha ha ha. Ha ha ha.
我54岁。好吧，所以我们年纪差不多。是的，你们怎么没碰到过对方？我现在在问一个问题，但我从来没有像现在这样出名又没被认可，所以很多事情对我来说都没意义。哈哈哈哈。哈哈哈哈。
Ha ha ha. Ha ha ha. Well, speaking of which, how many, I'm gonna guess right now, you're dealing with, you got a bunch of scripts that have been sent your way and you've read, I bet you there's two or three right now. Yeah, you're looking at two or three things right now
哈哈哈哈。哈哈哈哈。嗯，说到这个，有多少，我猜现在，你正在处理，你有一堆寄给你的剧本，你读过了，我敢打赌现在有两三个。是的，你现在正在看两三个东西，
that are like, what? I have a chance to do these things right now, but they conflict, and I gotta pick one. Like, are we in that moment right now? No, I've lived that before. I've felt, I've had that. Well, buddy, tuck in, buckle up. Which is the best choice to make,
就像，什么？我现在有机会做这些事情，但它们冲突了，我得选一个。就像，我们现在正处于那个时刻吗？不，我以前经历过。我感觉，我有过那个。嗯，伙计，塞进去，系好安全带。哪个是最好的选择，
and who will you disappoint if you don't do the following? Can you tell us what that was? Like, is there one that you can share now? It was years ago, it was years ago when I've been in that sort of dynamic of the industry, but right now, no, it's quiet. Right now, I don't have a job. Yeah, you know what they say about the quiet?
如果你不这样做，你会让谁失望？你能告诉我们那是什么吗？就像，有一个你现在可以分享的吗？那是几年前的事了，那是几年前我处于那种行业动态的时候，但现在，没有，很安静。我现在没有工作。是的，你知道他们怎么说安静吗？
It's right before the storm. That's right. Ha ha ha. He's right, Jason, that's right. Got a good set of reading glasses. Yeah, fuel up, get a lot of sleep right now while you can. Or I'll read them to you. I can read the script to you.
就在暴风雨之前。没错。哈哈哈哈。他是对的，杰森，没错。有一副好的老花镜。是的，加油，现在趁你能的时候多睡会儿。或者我读给你听。我可以读剧本给你听。
There you go, you got your fuel. It says Guinness on it, and I'm hoping it's coffee. It's a Guinness coffee cup, I've never seen that. I know, I like that. It's Earl Grey tea. Earl Grey tea, okay. Canadian. So you decide you're gonna be an actor, and you what?
给你，你有你的燃料。上面写着吉尼斯，我希望那是咖啡。这是一个吉尼斯咖啡杯，我从来没见过。我知道，我喜欢那个。是伯爵茶。伯爵茶，好吧。加拿大人。所以你决定你要成为一名演员，然后你做什么？
You move, you go, I'm gonna go to LA, or I'm gonna go to New York, where'd you do? Well, yeah, that was in Toronto, did that. My family lived in Seattle. Seattle. Seattle. Yes, in the Northwest. I didn't make it back for grade 13,
你搬家，你去，我要去洛杉矶，或者我要去纽约，你在哪里做的？嗯，是的，那是在多伦多，做了那个。我的家人住在西雅图。西雅图。西雅图。是的，在西北部。我没能赶回来上13年级，
because I didn't have the grades, and my father didn't have the money. So they said no honey, and so I had to make my decision as a kid of, I don't know, 17 years of age at that time. And I knew that I felt like I belonged, I felt like I was in a community, and when you're doing a play, you have a tribe for a short while, you know the drill.
因为我没有成绩，而且我父亲没有钱。所以他们说不，亲爱的，所以我不得不作为一个孩子，当时大概17岁，做出我的决定。我知道我觉得我属于那里，我觉得我在一个社区里，当你演戏时，你有一段时间有一个部落，你知道那个套路。
And I wanted to pursue that in a way, so I went and I got the last possible audition on the Labor Day weekend, like the Friday before this new semester started on the following Tuesday that year, 100 years ago, at Cornish College of the Arts. And I can't remember, but I auditioned, and I didn't hear anything, and then on that Tuesday morning, I called to ask,
我想以某种方式追求那个，所以我去了，我在劳动节周末得到了最后一个可能的试镜，就像那个新学期在那个周二开始之前的周五，100年前，在康沃尔艺术学院。我不记得了，但我试镜了，我没听到任何消息，然后在那个周二早上，我打电话问，
hey, do you guys like it? Am I in? What? And somebody did like one of these in the office. What's your name again? Frasier notes, it's Fraser, Fraser, yeah, you're in, can you come now? Yeah, nice.
嘿，你们喜欢吗？我进去了吗？什么？有人在办公室里做了这个动作。你叫什么名字来着？弗雷泽笔记，是弗雷泽，弗雷泽，是的，你进来了，你能现在过来吗？是的，不错。
So I got accepted, and the next thing I knew, I was signing my life away in like, Pell grants and student loans. This is in Seattle, yeah. In Seattle, and I started training, I had a four year program in conservatory, you know, after school, I did that for four years, that was very good, got a degree,
所以我被录取了，下一件事我知道，我正在签署我的生活，比如佩尔助学金和学生贷款。这是在西雅图，是的。在西雅图，我开始训练，我有一个四年的音乐学院课程，你知道，放学后，我做了四年，那非常好，拿到了学位，
and was in an internship in a theater then called Intamon, theater, that was a wild summer. The Russians showed up for the Goodwill Games, they was called, and the goodwill game. The entire Soviet Manic Company from Moscow brought three sisters, and I mean everything, all the little babushkas and other sets, and their laundry, everything.
然后在当时叫Intamon的剧院实习，那是一个疯狂的夏天。俄罗斯人为了友好运动会出现了，它叫那个，友好运动会。整个苏联Manic公司从莫斯科带来了三姐妹，我的意思是所有东西，所有的小巴布什卡和其他布景，还有他们的洗衣，所有东西。
And like, descended on his theater, we had a wild summer, I was basically just a de facto taxi driver, they all wanted to know where to go and buy some yoghurt. Medrugia, I want to buy a video magnet, which is roughly translated, my friend, I'd like to buy a VCR. Okay, right, sure.
就像，降临在他的剧院，我们度过了一个疯狂的夏天，我基本上只是一个事实上的出租车司机，他们都想知道去哪里买些酸奶。Medrugia，我想买一个录像磁带，大致翻译过来，我的朋友，我想买一台录像机。好吧，对，当然。
That's what I did that summer, and that ended, I had a great time, and I needed to figure it out, all right, well, here I am, like 20 years old. And then straight down to LA? Well, I had a scholarship that I'd earned to do graduate study if I wanted to, and I did, maybe, but it was at SMU in Dallas, and the new semester wasn't gonna start,
那就是我那个夏天做的事，然后结束了，我度过了一段美好的时光，我需要弄清楚，好吧，我在这里，大概20岁。然后直接去洛杉矶？嗯，我有一份奖学金，如果我想的话，我可以去读研究生，我确实想过，也许，但它在达拉斯的南卫理公会大学，新学期还没开始，
so I needed to get there. So I left Seattle, drove down the coast, and I stopped in Hollywood in California with the ignorant idea that I would, yeah, I'd make a little cash in this pilot season thing or whatever that was before I went to grad school the following semester, but that never happened. I met casting directors, and the ball started,
所以我需要去那里。所以我离开了西雅图，沿着海岸开车，我在加利福尼亚的好莱坞停了下来，带着无知的想法，我会，是的，我会在这个试播季之类的东西里赚点小钱，或者在下个学期去读研之前，但那从未发生。我遇到了选角导演，球开始滚动，
I got an agent, and I went to work, fortunately, pretty quickly. Wow, never made it to SMU. Never made it to SMU, I wrote him a letter. Did you have friends here? Did you have somebody you knew? Did you have a place to land? Yeah, no, I had a friend from college
我找了一个经纪人，幸运的是，我很快就开始工作了。哇，从来没去成南卫理公会大学。从来没去成南卫理公会大学，我给他们写了一封信。你有朋友在这里吗？你有认识的人吗？你有落脚的地方吗？是的，不，我有一个大学朋友，
whose mother had an apartment building, we shared a room in the valley by the airport, but I had a landing place, but other than that, no, I was just living out of my car. Jason uses an airport in the valley all the time. Somebody said L.E.X. to him the other day, and he said, what's that? Laxative, I'm plenty regular, what the...
他的母亲有一栋公寓楼，我们在机场旁边的山谷里合租了一个房间，但我有一个落脚的地方，但除此之外，没有，我只是住在我的车里。杰森一直使用山谷里的机场。有人前几天对他说了L.E.X.，他说，那是什么？泻药，我很规律，什么……
And we will be right back. Our thanks to Allbirds for their support. The thing about nature is, nature is better than processed. Can I say that? Is that controversial? I don't think it is. We all want stuff that's natural,
我们马上回来。感谢Allbirds的支持。关于大自然的事情是，大自然比加工过的好。我能这么说吗？这有争议吗？我不这么认为。我们都想要天然的东西，
because natural is better. And when it comes to quality and better, mother nature knows best. And you can take that idea and run with it with wool runners from Allbirds. Yeah. This year, trade your synthetic footwear for wool runners crafted with premium supernatural materials
因为天然的更好。当谈到质量和更好时，大自然母亲最清楚。你可以带着这个想法，用Allbirds的羊毛跑鞋去实践。是的。今年，用优质超自然材料制作的羊毛跑鞋换掉你的合成鞋，
that are comfy and durable, so you can run to the ends of the earth or the store. I wear the wool runner missiles, and they are unbelievable. I just wear them every day. I wear them with everything, and I wear them to when I'm running errands, or I wear them if I'm going to meetings,
它们舒适耐用，所以你可以跑到地球的尽头或商店。我穿羊毛跑鞋导弹，它们令人难以置信。我每天都穿它们。我穿它们搭配一切，我穿它们去跑腿，或者如果我要去开会，我也穿它们，
I wear them when I'm at home. I got these beautiful sort of their navy blue with like a white sole. They look really kind of chic and simple, and they're so unbelievably comfortable. They're really, really light. They form to your foot. You know, wool runners are built
我在家时也穿它们。我买了这些漂亮的，它们是海军蓝色的，带有白色鞋底。它们看起来非常时髦和简单，而且它们非常，非常舒适。它们真的，真的很轻。它们贴合你的脚。你知道，羊毛跑鞋是建立在
using premium supernatural materials with very low environmental impact, and they're constantly innovating to increase performance and longevity. So even on your toughest outings, you'll wear out long before your shoes do. And they're machine washable, so they look as fresh as the first day that you got them.
使用具有极低环境影响的优质超自然材料的基础上，而且它们不断创新以提高性能和寿命。所以即使在你最艰难的郊游中，你也会比你的鞋子先穿坏。而且它们可以用机器清洗，所以它们看起来和你得到它们的第一天一样新鲜。
And I can attest to that. Mine look very, very fresh. This year, take a big step forward from Mother Nature with the All Birds Wool Runner. Discover your perfect pair at allbirds.com today. That's A-L-L-B-I-R-D-S.com. This episode is brought to you in part by Visible. Family wireless plans are silly, right?
我可以证明这一点。我的看起来非常，非常新鲜。今年，用All Birds羊毛跑鞋向大自然母亲迈出一大步。今天就在allbirds.com发现你完美的一双。那是A-L-L-B-I-R-D-S.com。本集部分由Visible赞助。家庭无线计划很愚蠢，对吧？
Who decided that you should have to tie your phone service to your family's just to save money? Have you ever had to chase down a sister-in-law to get her to pay her share or quit hogging the data? Visible offers their best rate all on one line, not four lines, not three, not even two, just a one-line wireless plan, not even two, just a one-line wireless plan,
谁决定你必须把你的电话服务和你的家庭绑定在一起才能省钱？你有没有不得不追着嫂子让她付她的那份钱，或者别再占用数据了？Visible在一条线上提供他们最好的费率，不是四条线，不是三条，甚至不是两条，只是一条线无线计划，甚至不是两条，只是一条线无线计划，
not even three. Not even two, just a one-line wireless plan with unlimited data for $30 a month, taxes and fees included, all powered by Verizon. You get Visible's very best rate, even on a one-line wireless plan. Switch today at Visible.com and get $20 off your first month
甚至不是三条。甚至不是两条，只是一条线无线计划，每月30美元无限数据，包含税费，全部由Verizon提供支持。即使在一条线无线计划上，你也能获得Visible最好的费率。今天在Visible.com切换，并在你的第一个月获得20美元优惠，
when you use code SMARTLESS20. That's SMARTLESS20. A special offer for a smartless listener. Offer ends March 31st. New activation and offer code required. For data management practices, learn more at Visible.com. Additional terms apply. SMARTLESS is sponsored by BetterHelp.
当你使用代码SMARTLESS20时。那是SMARTLESS20。给smartless听众的特别优惠。优惠于3月31日结束。需要新的激活和优惠代码。有关数据管理实践，请在Visible.com了解更多。适用附加条款。SMARTLESS由BetterHelp赞助。
So we all like to feel our best self, right? And I feel my best self when I am infusing my values into my life. So there's a lot of things that you value, right? So for example, like I value nature. I like, I enjoy the outdoors and stuff like that. So if I go for a walk or a hike or I'm, you know, up in the mountains somewhere,
所以我们都喜欢感觉自己处于最佳状态，对吧？当我把我的价值观注入我的生活时，我感觉自己处于最佳状态。所以有很多你重视的东西，对吧？所以例如，我重视大自然。我喜欢，我享受户外活动之类的东西。所以如果我去散步或徒步旅行，或者我，你知道，在山上的某个地方，
whatever, I value that. And it makes me feel good. It makes me feel like my best self. So it's important to surround yourself with the things that you value in life, right? So when you're at your best, you can do great things. But sometimes life gets you bogged down and you may feel overwhelmed or like you're not showing up
无论如何，我重视那个。它让我感觉很好。它让我感觉自己处于最佳状态。所以围绕你生活中重视的东西是很重要的，对吧？所以当你处于最佳状态时，你可以做伟大的事情。但有时生活会让你陷入困境，你可能会感到不知所措，或者觉得你没有以你想要的方式表现出来，
in the way that you want to. Working with a therapist can help you get closer to the best version of you. Because when you feel empowered, you're more prepared to take on everything life throws at you. If you're thinking of giving therapy a try, BetterHelp is a great option. It's convenient, flexible, affordable, and entirely online.
与治疗师合作可以帮助你更接近最好的自己。因为当你感到被赋能时，你更有准备去应对生活抛给你的一切。如果你正在考虑尝试治疗，BetterHelp是一个很好的选择。它方便、灵活、负担得起，而且完全在线。
Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. If you want to live a more empowered life, therapy can get you there. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlist today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelpHELP.com slash smartlist.
只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可与持证治疗师匹配，并随时更换治疗师，无需额外费用。如果你想过一种更赋能的生活，治疗可以带你到达那里。今天访问betterhelp.com/smartlist，你的第一个月可享受10%的折扣。那是BetterHelpHELP.com/smartlist。
And now back to the show. All right, so you're in LA totally on your own basically and starting from scratch. And one thing leads to literally like maybe a play, commercials, episodics, feature. Here we go. I got cast in a pilot for Castle Rock. It was that's Rob Reiner's company, right?
现在回到节目。好吧，所以你完全独自一人在洛杉矶，基本上是从零开始。一件事导致了字面上就像可能是一部戏，广告，剧集，长片。开始了。我在《城堡岩》的试播集中被选中。那是罗伯·莱纳的公司，对吧？
Yep. Called My Old School from the producers of The Wonder Years. And it was about college kids. And it didn't get picked up, but that was fine because I needed the cash anyway. Sure. I'd done some auditions. I went in and read for a movie called School Ties.
是的。叫《我的老学校》，来自《奇迹岁月》的制片人。它是关于大学生的。它没有被选中，但这没关系，因为我反正需要钱。当然。我做了一些试镜。我进去读了一部叫《校园风云》的电影。
Sure. It didn't get hired. They were doing a big drift net search for whoever their David was going to be. Then I did get hired to go work with Martin Sheen in Pittsburgh on a jail movie about a guy who was wrongly accused and his father comes and breaks him off because that's really what Martin does really well,
当然。没被录用。他们正在为他们的戴维将是谁进行大规模的搜索。然后我确实被录用去匹兹堡和马丁·辛一起工作，拍一部关于一个被错误指控的人的监狱电影，他的父亲来把他救出来，因为那确实是马丁非常擅长的事情，
you know, fight the man. That was exciting. So I cut my teeth there. I worked in a real jail that was exciting and interesting and a little bit scary at the same time. Sure. I got mistaken for a prisoner. Except for wearing the same thing.
你知道，反抗体制。那很令人兴奋。所以我从那里开始磨练。我在一个真正的监狱里工作，那很令人兴奋、有趣，同时也有一点点可怕。当然。我被误认为是囚犯。除了穿着同样的东西。
That was scary. That sounds painful. Dax and I made that prison movie. Yes. We shot that. You're going to prison. A great movie. Let's go to prison.
那很可怕。听起来很痛苦。达克斯和我拍了那部监狱电影。是的。我们拍了那个。你要去监狱。一部伟大的电影。让我们去监狱。
Yeah, we shot it. Let's go to prison. No, you're right though. It was originally called You Are Going to Prison. That's the version I read. Turned it down. Then you did it. That sounds about right.
是的，我们拍了。让我们去监狱。不，你是对的。它最初叫《你要去监狱》。那是我读的版本。拒绝了。然后你做了。听起来很对。
No. That sounds about right. And we went to Joliet. We did it. And it's weird being in an actual prison. Let me just say, by the way, anybody in prison listening to that, by the way, if anybody listens to our podcast in prison, that's a good question.
不。听起来很对。我们去了乔利埃特。我们做了。在一个真正的监狱里很奇怪。顺便说一句，让我说，任何在监狱里听这个的人，顺便说一句，如果有人在监狱里听我们的播客，那是一个好问题。
You think they've got Wi-Fi in prisons. They can't, right? Or maybe they do. Are you allowed to... I think different securities, like, you know, levels. Depends on what wing you're in. Yeah. I think so, right?
你认为监狱里有Wi-Fi吗？他们不能，对吧？或者也许他们有。你被允许……我想不同的安全级别，比如，你知道，级别。取决于你在哪个侧翼。是的。我想是这样，对吧？
Yeah. I don't listen and it makes sense. Guys, let's workshop this real quick. Brendan, what do you think? Do you think that they have Wi-Fi in prison? I think they have everything there. No, but I'm not talking about, like, mulling in the Wi-Fi, you know. But, like, literally, like, that's below.
是的。我不听，这有道理。伙计们，让我们快速研讨一下这个。布兰登，你怎么看？你认为监狱里有Wi-Fi吗？我认为他们那里什么都有。不，但我不是在谈论，比如，在Wi-Fi里磨，你知道。但是，就像，字面上，就像，那在下面。
Yeah, you can have a TV. You can have Wi-Fi. And you can have... I think guys are mulling in routers up the rectum. Do you see routers coming all shapes and sizes now? Guys. What? Fuck.
是的，你可以有电视。你可以有Wi-Fi。而且你可以有……我想家伙们把路由器塞进直肠里。你现在看到路由器各种形状和大小了吗？伙计们。什么？该死。
Wait, what's mulling? What is mulling? Again, another sidebar for us. When people bring stuff... Keeping a list. You know, like, when you're, like, when you're getting on a plane from Bogota and you have to swallow, like, 15 or 20 condos filled with cocaine. Got it.
等等，什么是磨？什么是磨？又是我们的另一个侧边栏。当人们带东西……列个清单。你知道，就像，当你，就像，当你从波哥大坐飞机时，你不得不吞下，比如15或20个装满可卡因的避孕套。明白了。
Got it. You know? That's called mulling. Anyway, guys, I've heard enough people already this morning. So, Brendan, so, you're not mulling stuff into prison, but you're shooting a thing with Marty Sheen and then you come back and you... They want, they go, hey, we've re-designed, we've re-thought about it. We want you for a skintone.
明白了。你知道吗？那叫磨。总之，伙计们，我今天早上已经听够了。所以，布兰登，所以，你没有把东西磨进监狱，但你正在和马蒂·辛拍东西，然后你回来，你……他们想要，他们去，嘿，我们重新设计了，我们重新考虑了。我们想要你演一个肤色。
No, there was a new casting director as a shake-up in the Paramount structure. Stanley Jaffe was going to direct the picture. Wow. And then I think he was the studio boss, if I'm not mistaken. And then he stepped down to be a producer. And then Sherry Lansing came in to produce the picture. And she was running the studio at the time. And so it was, like, a new day.
不，派拉蒙结构中有一个新的选角导演变动。斯坦利·贾菲要导演这部电影。哇。然后我想如果我没记错的话，他是工作室老板。然后他辞职去当制片人。然后雪莉·兰辛进来制作这部电影。她当时在经营工作室。所以，就像，新的一天。
And so they started casting again. And I went in again, like, just like when I got into college. It was the last absolute appointment. And I read for a new casting director who said, you should meet Sherry. I did. I read. She said, I want to test you. And I thought, first, like an exam.
所以他们又开始选角了。我又进去了，就像我上大学时一样。那是最后一个绝对的预约。我为一位新的选角导演读了剧本，他说，你应该见见雪莉。我见了。我读了。她说，我想测试你。我想，首先，像考试一样。
Like, you know, I thought sharpened pencils. You felt like some variety test right then and there. Yeah, exactly. Just straight line hands. She was like, what are you doing tomorrow? I'm like, I don't know. I'm doing it. So I'm going to do a screen test with Matt Damon.
就像，你知道，我想削尖铅笔。你当时感觉就像某种多样性测试。是的，完全正确。只是直线手。她就像，你明天做什么？我像，我不知道。我在做。所以我去和马特·达蒙做屏幕测试。
And you tested with Damon? Yes. Yes. Yes. We did like one or two scenes. Memory search. No kidding. He was so good. I mean, we never got hired if it wasn't for him.
你和达蒙测试了？是的。是的。是的。我们做了一两场戏。记忆搜索。不开玩笑。他太棒了。我的意思是，如果不是因为他，我们永远不会被录用。
Yeah. He used to be so good. I agree with you. And then he used to be great. Film by film. Yeah. Slowly deteriorated. All the town atrophy.
是的。他过去常常那么好。我同意你的看法。然后他过去常常很伟大。一部电影接一部电影。是的。慢慢恶化。所有的城镇萎缩。
And now we're left with what we got now. And we like it. We like it. Fun. Fun to look at. And it's fun. Fun to listen to. But yeah.
现在我们只能接受现状了。而且我们喜欢这样。我们喜欢它。很有趣。看起来很有趣。而且它很有趣。听起来也很有趣。但确实。
But what's he ever done? Very little. He's he now did school ties and then all downhill. You know what, Brendon? You know what Matt Damon's been relegated to? He's relegated to fourth place in the oct, Quirtle daily puzzle game. Which every day.
但他到底做过什么？很少。他现在演了《校园风云》，然后就走下坡路了。你知道吗，布兰登？你知道马特·达蒙被降级到什么地步了吗？他在《Quirtle》每日益智游戏中被降级到了第四名。每天都是这样。
Local news. I think he's my neighbor. He lives up. Yes, he is. He is your neighbor. According to the rag that reports on if a raccoon gets sick. And I know you know him from way back, but don't approach him these days.
本地新闻。我觉得他是我邻居。他住在那上面。是的，他就是。他确实是你的邻居。根据那份报道浣熊是否生病的破报纸上说的。我知道你很久以前就认识他，但最近别去打扰他。
He's very cantankerous now. Easy. Yeah. He's just had such bad luck with the morning games. He tries this puzzle game that we're in. And it's been tough. He's got to change his starter word. He does have to change the start.
他现在脾气很暴躁。放轻松。是啊。他最近在晨间游戏上运气太差了。他尝试了我们正在玩的这个益智游戏。而且很难。他得换个起始词。他确实得换个起始词。
He's had a tough time. He keeps going with vowels. You got to go to consonants. So you do school ties. This movie puts you on the map. And it was kind of like I said in the intro, it was a one, two punch. You do school ties with which did quite well at the box office.
他最近过得很艰难。他一直用元音。你得用辅音。所以你演了《校园风云》。这部电影让你声名鹊起。就像我在开场白里说的那样，这就像一套组合拳。你演了《校园风云》，它在票房上表现相当不错。
I mean, wasn't a smash hit, but it was, but it did quite well. It was well received. And then you do Encino Man with Pauly Shore, which again also made a ton of money and was a big hit. Especially, you know, I looked it up compared to its box office. Both these films were legitimate hits for the makers of the film. And this is like a, this is a heck of an intro to entertainment. You have two back to back really successful films.
我是说，虽然不是大爆款，但确实表现不错。反响很好。然后你又演了保利·肖尔主演的《原始人》，那部电影也赚了很多钱，是个大热门。特别是，你知道，我查了一下它的票房对比。这两部电影对制片方来说都是名副其实的成功之作。这简直是进入娱乐圈的绝佳开场。你连续两部电影都非常成功。
Was it just on after that? Once this was the release of both these things, was that the moment Jason described? Yeah, it was. Wide collars, Ferraris. No, but like everything. Cousins. Vegas. Oh, yeah.
那之后就一直这样吗？一旦这两部作品发布，那是杰森描述的那个时刻吗？是的，就是那样。宽领带，法拉利。不，就像所有东西一样。表亲。维加斯。哦，是的。
A bunch of small dogs. Little lap dogs. Yeah. You need a dog. Cousins. Bonbons. Broads. Broads everywhere.
一群小狗。小哈巴狗。是的。你需要一只狗。表亲。糖果。辣妹。到处都是辣妹。
This time I had a Yorkshire Terrier in my lap. And you didn't know. Did you have it the whole time? Yes. Listener, we just saw Yorkshire Terrier run through the shot. Do you know that dog? It's my dog. It's supposed to be in your house.
这次我怀里抱着一只约克夏梗。你当时不知道吗？你一直抱着它吗？是的。听众朋友们，我们刚才看到一只约克夏梗跑进了镜头。你认识那只狗吗？那是我的狗。它应该待在你家里的。
All right. Yeah, that's Pee Wee. It's just the security. Pee Wee. Beware. So B-phrase. Yes. You, I don't know.
好吧。是的，那是皮威。它只是安保。皮威。小心。所以是B短语。是的。你，我不知道。
So when those movies hit, was it kind of like how did you process that? Because if it's your first two and there, did you just think, oh, this is how this goes. I'll be set. In a way, I did. I mean, I wasn't so naive that I thought, well, everybody does this. I know they don't. But I knew that this was a good entree, a good calling card. And I think if you're making diverse choices, then people are bound to pay a little bit
那么当那些电影火了之后，你是怎么处理的？因为如果那是你的前两部作品，你当时是不是想，哦，原来这就是演艺圈啊。我以后稳了。某种程度上，我是这么想的。我是说，我还没天真到以为每个人都能这样。我知道他们不能。但我知道这是一个很好的入场券，一张很好的名片。而且我认为如果你做出多元化的选择，人们肯定会多关注一点。
more attention. Like, wait, no, you're a comedy guy. No, you're a drama guy. You can't pick those. But in this case, I guess lightning struck or something. And I was fortunate that way. And then I went on to do a bunch of good stuff. So in those days, they were called independent films, low budgets that they were.
比如，等等，不，你是演喜剧的。不，你是演正剧的。你不能选那些。但在这种情况下，我想是好运降临了。我很幸运。然后我继续演了一堆好作品。在那个年代，它们被称为独立电影，预算很低。
Yes, I know. Like independent of what? Independent of a business daddy letting you have distribution or independent of someone breathing down your neck, making creative choices from far, far away from behind a desk. Maybe, but, you know, anyway, so I was keeping busy in that whole world. That's for sure. Right. Right.
是的，我知道。独立于什么？独立于那些让你获得发行的商业大佬，还是独立于那些在遥远办公室里对你指手画脚、进行创作干预的人？也许吧，但不管怎样，我一直在那个世界里忙碌。那是肯定的。对，对。
And so we go through that sort of working actors, staying busy, all that stuff. And then, I mean, do we jump? Will, I don't want to, I don't want to jump your timeline on your questions here. But Darren Aronofsky calls. Yeah. Or, or did you find it and call him? Which is the whale? Yes.
所以我们经历了那种职业演员的状态，保持忙碌，诸如此类。然后，我是说，我们要跳过吗？威尔，我不想，我不想跳过你问题的时间线。但达伦·阿伦诺夫斯基打电话来了。是的。还是你发现了这个项目并联系了他？是《鲸》吗？是的。
A lot, a lot, a lot happened. And so I was, I was in the middle of a lot of stuff and career and ups and downs and this stuff that we all go through and grow and learn from and all that. And that's great. And I did hear from Darren. And initially the word on the street was, Darren's going to make a movie. And would you like to meet him? The answer is yes, absolutely.
发生了很多很多事。我当时正处于事业的起伏期，经历着我们所有人都会经历、成长并从中学习的事情。那很好。我确实收到了达伦的消息。起初坊间传闻，达伦要拍一部电影。你想见见他吗？答案是肯定的，绝对想。
You know, anybody who carries bag. Yeah. I was really intimidated when I first met him in his offices in Chinatown. That was in January of 2020. But he, and he, he was really forthcoming about the party. He said it's about, I didn't know anything other than it's about a guy who's been living alone and he's been, he's been overeating. He's been harming himself that way.
你知道，任何背着包的人。是的。我第一次在唐人街的办公室见到他时，真的很紧张。那是2020年1月。但他，他非常坦诚地谈到了这个角色。他说这是关于，我除了知道这是一个独自生活、暴饮暴食、以这种方式伤害自己的男人之外，什么都不知道。
And whether he means to or not is, you know, up for interpretation and he has a strained relationship with his daughter and he has an epiphany that he, if he doesn't reconnect it's very soul is at stake. And that's about all I knew. I mean, and Darren said, I need to cast an actor. First of all, who can play the part, but at the same time we'll be able to create Charlie from the outside in with, and he was said, we have to do it with prosthetics. And he'd worked with Adrian Moreau several times previously.
至于他是否有意为之，那是见仁见智的，他和女儿的关系很紧张，他突然意识到如果他不重新建立联系，他的灵魂就岌岌可危了。我只知道这些。我是说，达伦说，我需要找一个演员。首先，他能演这个角色，但同时他能从外到内塑造查理，他说，我们必须用假体化妆来完成。他之前和阿德里安·莫罗合作过好几次。
It was fantastic. So good at his job. Was it a makeup artist? Yes. Yeah. Because it was, you know, January 2020, COVID was looming and, you know, March rolled around after we did a reading of it. Yeah.
太棒了。他工作非常出色。他是化妆师吗？是的。因为当时是2020年1月，新冠疫情即将来临，你知道，我们在读完剧本后，三月就到了。是的。
We all went home for a while, clearly. Yeah. But I got hired to work with Steven Soderbergh. Again, I worked with him back in the day on a series for Showtime of Fallen Angels and they were like these shorts that were being directed. Anyway, but he called up to play the bag man in No Sudden Move with Don Cheadle. Yeah. Really great cast.
我们显然都回家待了一段时间。是的。但我被雇去和史蒂文·索德伯格合作。我以前在Showtime的系列剧《堕落天使》中和他合作过，那是些短片。总之，他打电话让我去演《切肤之痛》里的那个接头人，和唐·钱德尔一起。是的。演员阵容真的很棒。
And Darren texted me and he sent this research material and he was kind of like, you know, get on it. And I didn't know if I was hired or not. I had to actually ask him. I'm like, I'm sorry, did I get the part? He's like, yes, you did. Now get the word. Great.
达伦给我发了短信，他发了一些研究资料，他就像是，你知道，开始准备吧。我不知道我是否被录用了。我不得不问他。我说，抱歉，我拿到这个角色了吗？他说，是的，你拿到了。现在去准备吧。太棒了。
And from there we started in January of 2021. Rehearsing for the whale for three weeks, which is great because A24 is very filmmaker and actor friendly, supportive. They do everything like everything they touch works. You see A24. It's eye-opening. You know, you want to, you want to know what they're up to. They take, they take fair creative risks.
从那时起，我们在2021年1月开始了。为《鲸》排练了三周，这很棒，因为A24公司对电影制作人和演员非常友好、支持。他们做的一切，就像他们触碰的一切都能成功。你看到A24。这让人大开眼界。你知道，你想知道他们在做什么。他们承担了合理的创作风险。
And you know, I guess financial ones too, but it's not my wheelhouse, but yes, they're they're really great. And so we, like everyone at that time started working with all the protocols and safety measures and everything. And we were about to start shooting and then I got COVID. Oh, wow. So that was... Did you have an easy time with it?
你知道，我想还有财务风险，但那不是我的专长，但是的，他们真的很棒。所以我们，像当时每个人一样，开始在所有的协议和安全措施下工作。我们正要开始拍摄，然后我得了新冠。哦，哇。所以那是……你当时过得轻松吗？
Were you one of the lucky ones? I lost my taste and my smell and I was really stupider than I normally am. Like I had brain fog, you know, like it's sleeping a lot. Yeah. But we started. We got going. We worked under, everyone worked under existential threat. Will there be a tomorrow?
你是幸运儿之一吗？我失去了味觉和嗅觉，而且比平时更笨。就像我有脑雾，你知道，睡得很多。是的。但我们开始了。我们动起来了。我们在存在主义威胁下工作。明天还会到来吗？
Right. We were all the same way. And it really added to the, the, I think the film in a great way. And what kind of research did he send you? Because it was a play. Was it not? That's right. Yeah.
对。我们都一样。这确实以一种很好的方式增加了电影的质感。他给你发了什么样的研究资料？因为那是一部舞台剧，不是吗？没错。是的。
Oh, it was? Samuel D. Hunter had produced this at New Horizons in 2012 where Darren first saw it and then optioned it from him. Oh, wow. And they developed it for 10 years. Oh, wow. And Sam Hunter adapted his own stage play for the screen also. First time.
哦，是吗？塞缪尔·D·亨特在2012年的新视野剧院制作了这部戏，达伦在那里第一次看到它，然后从他那里买下了版权。哦，哇。他们开发了10年。哦，哇。山姆·亨特还亲自将自己的舞台剧改编成了电影剧本。第一次。
I mean, not bad. That's his first, first, first, seriously. Wow. Wow. Wow. Like, wow. You know, talent doesn't, doesn't go away. I guess they say.
我是说，不错。那是他的第一次，第一次，真的。哇。哇。哇。就像，哇。你知道，天赋不会消失。我想他们是这么说的。
No. Well, you know, that, that one clip of you. Sometimes it never shows up at all. Go ahead, John. Sorry. Perfect timing. The clip of you where, the clip of you where you were in the audience. I don't know where it was watching a screening of, of the whale.
不。好吧，你知道，那个关于你的片段。有时它根本就不会出现。继续，约翰。抱歉。时机完美。那个你在观众席的片段，那个你在观众席看《鲸》放映的片段。
And you had this unex, what seemed like an unexpected standing ovation. And it, you got so emotional and I got emotional watching you get emotional. And I hadn't even seen the movie yet, but just that clip was so powerful just to see you standing up, receiving all of those accolades. It was really, really cool to see that. That was, that's a core memory for me now. What I was looking at is 1200 Italians. If you don't see, you're all screaming and crying.
你得到了那种意想不到的起立鼓掌。你变得非常激动，我看着你激动我也变得激动。我当时还没看过电影，但仅仅那个片段就非常有力量，看到你站起来，接受所有的赞美。看到那一幕真的很酷。那现在是我心中的核心记忆。我当时看着的是1200个意大利人。如果你没看到，他们都在尖叫和哭泣。
So it's kind of infectious. I think everyone has to sort of like mild group hysteria. I think it goes on for long enough. I was trying to get out of the, and Darren's like, no, take a bow. He's the boss. Yeah. So the conversation. So it was a combination as far as the look of the whale, which for those who don't know
所以这有点传染性。我想每个人都有点像轻微的群体歇斯底里。我想这持续了足够长的时间。我当时想离开，达伦说，不，鞠个躬。他是老板。是的。所以对话。所以这是一个结合，关于《鲸》的造型，对于那些不知道的人来说
is about someone who's very, very overweight. Yeah. And consequently homebound, right? Correct. So the conversation was, was it going to be all prosthetics or did that kind of evolve into, well, you know, Darren, I think I can, I can put on X number of these pounds practically. And then we kind of augment with the, with the, with the makeup. How did that, those conversations go?
是关于一个非常非常超重的人。是的。因此被困在家里，对吧？正确。所以对话是，是全部使用假体，还是演变成，嗯，你知道，达伦，我想我可以，我可以实际上增加X磅的体重。然后我们用化妆来辅助。那些对话是怎么进行的？
I had to meet the guy halfway, you know, on paper. It says he's 600. That's just a number. 600 pounds. I, the research that he'd sent was documentary footage was interviews with, you know, I mean, the point is, is the man is serious mobility issues. He can't get up off of his couch and without it being a Herculean effort, which was important as a plot point to the film.
我得和那个人达成某种平衡，你知道，在纸面上。上面写着他有600磅。那只是个数字。600磅。我，他发给我的研究资料是纪录片片段，是采访，你知道，我的意思是，重点是，这个人的行动能力有严重问题。他无法从沙发上站起来，除非付出巨大的努力，这作为电影的情节重点很重要。
If you come see it, you'll understand why. But I, I guess I just had to go with what I had and try and meet the character more or less halfway, I think. What did that involve for you practically? Well, four hours of makeup in the morning, you know, we're all, look, I'm an actor and you are too. I love my job. I don't have a problem.
如果你来看，你就会明白为什么。但我，我想我只能用我所拥有的，尽量和角色达成某种平衡。这对你来说实际上意味着什么？嗯，早上四个小时的化妆，你知道，我们都是，看，我是个演员，你也是。我热爱我的工作。我没问题。
I could sleep when you're dead, you know, and, and, and besides Adrian was there an hour before and an hour after. So, you know, I'm not going to cry anyone in any tears, but, um, yeah, it was an extensive process to just be patient, be a patient, patient, but, but meeting him halfway meant that you had to, you had to bulk up and you had to work on your diet and you had to add things. What was that process like? And did it ever feel scary?
死后自有长眠，你知道，而且阿德里安提前一小时到，晚走一小时。所以，你知道，我不会向任何人哭诉，但是，嗯，是的，这是一个漫长的过程，要保持耐心，做一个耐心的病人，但是，和他在中间达成平衡意味着你必须，你必须增重，你必须调整饮食，你必须增加一些东西。那个过程是怎样的？有没有感到害怕？
We had that conversation. We just said, you know what? The concern was that Brandon, don't go and lose weight now because then the prosthetics won't work because they were created with a scan because we couldn't get together and pour the goop on your face and make a mold. You know? So the producer came in and he held an iPad up to me in my driveway, you know, 15 feet away from each other.
我们有过那次对话。我们只是说，你知道吗？担心的是布兰登，现在别去减肥，因为那样假体就没法用了，因为它们是根据扫描创建的，因为我们没法聚在一起把胶水倒在你脸上做模具。你知道吗？所以制片人进来了，他在我的车道上举着iPad对着我，你知道，我们相距15英尺。
And that data went to, went to Montreal and Adrian created Charlie virtually, which is important because the body itself becomes a texture map. You can create clearly anything. I mean, he had control over the size of the pores, the placement of them, little anomalies in the skin stretch, all that stuff. And, and it skips a step in the regular process, which is sculpting by hand, compounding and all that. So it was interesting because this is pretty sure like the future of how we're going to
数据传到了蒙特利尔，阿德里安虚拟地创造了查理，这很重要，因为身体本身变成了一张纹理贴图。你可以清楚地创造任何东西。我是说，他可以控制毛孔的大小、位置、皮肤拉伸的细微异常，所有这些。它跳过了常规过程中的一步，即手工雕刻、合成等等。所以这很有趣，因为这很确定是未来我们进行假体化妆的方式。我是说，而且它是无缝的。它是无缝的。我是说，我曾经拍过一部叫《神鬼愿望》的电影，是哈罗德·雷米斯的作品，我化了五六种不同的全套假体妆，我回去又看了一遍。那是马修·芒格的作品，他太棒了。他已经退休了。他是个很棒的人。
be doing prosthetics this point forward. I mean, and it's, it's seamless. It's seamless. I mean, I had been, I did a movie called bedazzled a Harold Ramis picture and I, I was in five or six different full on prosthetic makeups and I went back and looked at him again. That was Matthew Mungle's work and he's fantastic. He's since retired. He's a great guy.
而且你仍然可以看到，你知道，它看起来更手工。你知道，你暂停你的怀疑来接受你所看到的东西。而对于《鲸》和查理，它根本不是数字创作。有报道说它是数字创作，那是错误的，它不是，我是说，除了可能在后期处理中去掉的围兜上的接缝，对吧，或者如果织物在上面起皱了。那不在乎。那不在乎。
And you can, you can still see like, you know, it looks more handmade. You know, you, you suspend your disbelief to, to buy into what you're looking at. And with the whale and Charlie, it's not a digital creation at all. It's been wrongly reported that it is, it's not, I mean, with the exception of maybe a seam on a bib that got taken out in post, right, or if the fabric was acting, acting up on it. That doesn't care. That doesn't care.
那不在乎。不，它不在乎。我是说，但说真的，除此之外，你知道，是模拟的，是一个演员。好吧，我认为你做这些是有方法的，我当然作为演员，杰森，你可能对此有发言权。我是说，你做过的所有手术，你觉得那就像是更永久的化妆吗？你是这么看的吗？
That doesn't care. No, it doesn't. I mean, but seriously, otherwise it was, you know, analog, an actor. Well, I think that there are ways that you do, I certainly as actors and Jason, you can probably speak to this. I mean, all the, all the surgery that you've had, do you find that that is just kind of like, like more permanent makeup? Is that what you look at?
它是更永久的，但德里，我们确实需要对一些钉子进行大量的数字移除。但这减少了在椅子上的时间。是的。等等，布兰登，让我问你，让我问你问题。所以你，你有一段非常漫长、复杂的关系，不是和表演，因为你在你所做的事情上一直很稳定，而是和演艺圈，你对它有什么感觉？
It's more permanent, but Derry, we do have to do a lot of digital removals of some of the staples. But it cuts down time in the chair. Yes. Wait, Brendan, let me ask you, let me ask you questions. So you, you've had a very long, complicated relationship, not with acting, because you've always been consistent in what you do, but with show business, where do you, what do you feel about it?
你现在和演艺圈的关系如何，比如，你发现，你发现自己对它有矛盾的感觉吗，但商业运作的方式以及所有这些事情，它是如何改变的，或者它是如何改变的，或者你，你学到了东西，还是你觉得，你是愤世嫉俗的，还是我不知道？我，我经历过这个行业的许多迭代。我是说，我咬牙坚持了20年左右。而且你知道，我看到了很多事情，嗯，2009年左右，随着我拍的一部电影，一切都从马车变成了内燃机，
How is your relationship with show business now in terms of like, do you find, did you, do you find yourself like having conflicting feelings about it, but the way that the way that the business works and all that stuff, how it's changed or how it's changed or how you, have you learned stuff or do you feel, are you cynical or are you, I don't know? I've, I've been through many iterations of the business. I mean, I, I white knuckled it for 20 years or so. And you know, I saw a lot of things, well, did the advent of everything kind of going to horse and cart to internal combustion engine around 2009 with, with a movie that I did,
那是《阿凡达》的测试版。它叫《地心历险记》3D，你知道，那项技术和那些摄像机一起经过了实战测试。那去了新西兰，詹姆斯·卡梅隆，你知道，然后用那些拍了《阿凡达》。所以我这么说是因为，你知道，我们都从某种模拟世界进入了数字世界，那确实改变了很多行业。我是说，任何事情，任何事情都是可能的，它提高了我们能做什么以及我们将接受我们所看到的东西的赌注。
which was the beta for avatar. It was called journey to center of the earth in 3d, you know, and that technology was being battle tested along with those cameras. And that went to New Zealand and James Cameron, you know, then made avatar from those. So I say this because, you know, we all kind of went from a sort of analog world to a digital world and that really changed the business a lot too. I mean, anything, anything is possible and it up the stakes in terms of what we can do and what we will accept about what we're seeing.
然后那又变了，当然。所以我们现在到了2023年，所有这些华丽的图像都可以相对便宜地为你想做的任何事情创造出来。我们发现自己处于一个必须，你必须让自己与众不同，你必须，你必须回归讲故事。我想，你知道，只是保持花哨的东西很棒，我喜欢那些东西。我真的喜欢。但你必须回归，你知道，演员的一二三。
Then that changed again, of course. So here we are now in 2023 and all of these slick images can be created on the relative cheap for anything you want to do. And we find ourselves in a place where you have to, you have to differentiate yourself, you have to, you have to get back to storytelling. I think, you know, just hold the bells and whistles are great and I love that stuff. I really do. But you have to get back to, you know, the one, two, threes of an actor.
我从这个中想要什么，你知道，我怎么得到它？障碍是什么？谁是，我将使用什么策略，然后交叉手指，你知道，当我，当我年轻的时候，当我年轻的时候，作为演员的游戏和现在完全不同，对吧？当你，你知道，在80年代和90年代，无论什么，它是，这是我的照片和简历。我得烦我的经纪人。我去试镜。
What do I want from this, you know, how am I going to get it? What's the obstacle? Who's, what tactic will I use and then cross your fingers and, you know, when I, when I was younger, when I was younger, the game was so much different as an actor that it is now, right? When you were, you know, in the 80s and 90s, whatever, it was, here's my picture and resume. I got to bug my agent. I go on an audition.
我坐着等电话响，就是这样。现在，你知道，如果人们说，你知道，我会，我会，我姐姐说，嘿，我女儿的一个朋友想进入这个行业。你有什么建议？你知道，就像你现在几乎必须成为一切。你必须成为编剧、制片人、导演、演员。你必须在YouTube上创造你自己的东西或创造你自己的内容。肖恩，我们，我们那天晚上谈到了它。
I sit and wait for the phone to ring and that's it. Now, you know, if people say what, you know, I'll, I'll, my sister say, hey, a friend of my daughter's wants to get into the business. What's your advice? You know, it's like you almost have to be everything now. You have to be a writer, producer, director, actor. You have to create your own stuff on YouTube or create your own content. Sean, we, we, we talked about it the other night.
你和我谈到了它。是的。我们谈到了，有多难，肖恩和我都在说，天哪，现在作为演员起步太难了。是的。抱歉伙计们。没关系。你被解雇了。
You and I talked about it. Yeah. We talked about how, how hard it would be, Sean and I were both saying, God, be so hard starting as an actor right now. Yeah. Sorry guys. That's all good. You're fired.
皮威。我们要把皮威找回来。嘿。可怜的狗刚丢了工作。但我们当时在谈论这个想法，对吧，肖恩，如果你今天作为演员起步会非常难，你知道，你，你得到一份工作，呃，你知道，在流媒体，或者，或者电视网什么的，而且，你知道，什么都没有，看起来不像。也许有，但现在没有什么能拍一百集了。
Peewee. We're gonna get Peewee back. Hey. Poor dog just lost his job. But we were talking about the idea of right, Sean, that it would be so hard if you were starting today as an actor, you know, you, you get a job, uh, you know, on a, on a streamer or, or a network or something and, you know, nothing goes, it doesn't seem like it. Maybe it does, but nothing goes for a hundred episodes anymore.
所以作为演员得到一份工作，这就是生活，你从一个工作到另一个工作。但看起来越来越不像了，你得到某样东西的六集，然后你必须在这些短得不能再短的剧集之间奔波寻找另一个工作，而且它们似乎越来越短。但我的观点是，我的问题是，这其中有任何，你做这个，嗯，你做吗？你的一部分想，你因为你的提问能力被提名了。哦，是的。
So to get a gig as an actor, that's the life you go gig to gig. But it seems like it's less and less like you get six episodes of something and then you have to pound the pavement to find another gig in between these short, short, short runs and they seem to be getting shorter and shorter. But my point is, and my question is, does any of that, do you do this, um, do you do it? Does any part of you want to, you got nominated for your question asking abilities. Oh yeah.
抱歉，布兰登，你知道我们三个中，肖恩去年被提名为年度主持人。年度主持人。他们实际上拆散了三人组。他们只是把他挑出来说，不，他在采访方面显然是最好的，你坐在前排看到了原因。所以看看这个，布兰登，肖恩得到了我的票，我们三个中最差的一个选我。
Sorry, Brendan, you know that of the three of us, Sean was nominated for host of the year last year. Host of the year. They actually, they broke up the threesome. They just, they singled him out and said, no, he's clearly the best at interviewing and you got a front row seat as to why. So check this out, Brendan, Sean got my vote, which is three of us is the worst one to pick me.
但不管怎样，我的问题，不，你没赢。好吧。这只是个跟进。那里没有赢，第二年他们纠正了错误，不是我们三个。但看看这个，布兰登，去，再也听不到，再也听不到我了。但我的观点是，这其中有任何，如果如果你喜欢那个，请原谅我，我只是不知道，但你的一部分想成为，你说了多少次你喜欢，原谅
But anyway, my question, no, you didn't win. Okay. It was just to follow up. There was not a win there and the following year they corrected their mistake and it's not the three of us. But check this out, Brendan, go, never to be heard of again, heard from again me. But my point is, does any of that, and forgive me if you are into that, and I just don't know, but is any of you want to be, how many times have you said that you like, forgive
如果你喜欢这个，但继续，不，但我确实想知道，那些其他方面有任何激励你吗，想让你做那些其他事情，写作、导演、制作、主演，所有这些事情同时进行，还是你觉得，你知道吗，我喜欢保持这种演员的单一轨道。我现在要保持在我的轨道上。我是说，我也，我非常懒，而且有点像个勒德分子。所以，而且有这么多我想合作的好导演。而且，我是说，我还有很多东西要探索。
me if you are into this, but go ahead, no, but I do want to know, does any of those other facets inspire you, want you to kind of do any of those other things, write, direct, produce, star, all of those things at the same time, or you're like, you know what, I like staying in this one lane of being an actor. I'm going to stay in my lane for now. I mean, I also, I'm spectacularly lazy and somewhat of a leadite too. So, and there's so many good directors that I want to work with. And also, I mean, I have a lot to still explore.
是的，有了这个，所以保持，你想保持专注于纯粹的表演，这完全令人钦佩，而且你真的想和所有这些导演合作，所以考虑到这个推测的再次相关时刻，我们总是都在努力争取，就像是，让我得到一次击球机会。所以有那次伟大的击球，你知道，随着所有这些伟大的、当之无愧的恶名即将到来。你有一个，我不会问你的目标或计划，或者甚至想到那个程度，但你已经完成了这么多，而且你已经在
Yeah, and with that, so staying, you want to stay focused purely on the acting, which is totally admirable, and you really want to work with all these directors, so given this presumed moment of relevance, again, which we're always all striving for, is just like, let me get an at-bat. So there's the great at-bat, you know, coming up here with all this great, well-deserved notoriety. Do you have a, I'm not going to ask you for your goal or your plan, or to the extent to even have thought about that, but you've accomplished so much and you've been in the
这个行业待了这么久。如果你允许自己做一点梦，你希望你在行业里的下一阶段时间怎么过？我想再次持续地在长片中工作。我对，你知道，流媒体体验和做短项目感到非常高兴，比如为FX做的《信任》，唐纳德·萨瑟兰和丹尼·博伊尔导演了那个。我是说，在流媒体中确实有令人兴奋的事情要做。我们都知道。
business for such a long time. How would you like this next stage of your time in the business to go if you allow yourself to dream a little bit? I want to work in features consistently, again. I have been really happy with, you know, the streaming experiences and doing short projects like Trust for FX with Donald Sutherland and Danny Boyle directed that. I mean, there's really exciting things to be done. We all know that in streaming.
但说到肖恩的观点，是的，它同时也可能非常有限，这有利有弊。对于接下来的一切，伙计们，这是一条开放的道路。你只是想保持工作，是吗？但在长片中。本质上，我确实想。我是说，我仍然一直有这种感觉。我是那个在西雅图的孩子，有人会走过来递给我一条洗碗巾。
But to Sean's point, yeah, it can be really limiting at the same time, too, which has pros and cons. For whatever's next, guys, it's an open road. You just want to stay working, yeah? But in features. Essentially, I do. I mean, I still always have this feeling. I'm that kid back in Seattle and someone's going to walk up to me and hand me a dish
是的，当然。吸引力是，抱歉，吸引力是因为你有一种真正的兴奋感去变形成不是你的角色吗？就像那是一种纯粹的表演热情，还是成为团队努力的一部分，在一些非常有才华的导演的指导下建立一部电影？就像是什么真正让你对这一切感到兴奋？是的，这两点都是极好的观点。
towel. Yeah, for sure. And is the draw, sorry, is the draw because you have a real excitement to morph into characters that are not you? Like is that like a pure acting passion, or is it to be a part of a team effort to build a film under the tutelage of some really talented director? Like what's the thing that really excites you about it all? Yes, both of those are excellent points.
那个，而且我也很想重温那些确实令人兴奋的事情，我能够做的，比如《木乃伊》，你知道，那些大型特许经营作品。我喜欢它。那些真的，我是说，它只是变得显而易见。真的，我是说，20多年后的重要性现在才在我身上觉醒。你想拍《木乃伊》的另一部续集吗？哦，是的。
That and also I'd love to do revisit things that really were exciting that I got to do, like the mummy, you know, those big franchise pieces. I loved it. Those really, I mean, it's just becoming apparent. Really I mean, the gravity of it is really 20 whatever years later is just awakening with me now. You'd like to do another sequel to the mummy. Oh, yeah.
我们现在在制造新闻吗？是的，那是。我们得到了。我十年来一直在屋顶上尖叫这个。给我们一些新的东西。给我们一些新鲜的东西。我想我听到你说你想拍《校园风云》，那很难说。那木乃伊的爸爸呢？
Are we making news right now? Yeah, that's. We've got it. I've been screaming this from the rooftops for 10 years. Give us something new. Give us something fresh. I think I heard you say you want to do school ties to what that would be hard to say. What about the daddy?
那木乃伊的爸爸，然后爸爸，跟上。好吧。我们正在做松散的词语联想，这甚至不聪明和/或机智。但你想进入某种特许经营，可能还有《木乃伊》。带回来。哦，天哪。你知道我的意思吗？我是说，我知道。
What about the daddy to the mummy and then the daddy, just keep up. Okay. We're doing loose word association is just it's not even clever and or witty. But you'd like to get into some sort of a franchise and potentially the mummy. Bring it back. Oh my God. You know what I mean? I mean, I know.
克鲁斯跳进去了一会儿吗？汤姆·克鲁斯没有吗？哦，是的。是的，他做了。是的。但你喜欢你喜欢的是你喜欢你喜欢那些大型、巨大、有趣的好莱坞大片，因为你拍了一堆。你想再拍一部那样的。
Did he cruise jump in there for a minute? Didn't Tom Cruise? Oh, yes. Yeah, he did. Yeah. But you like you like what you're saying is you like you like that you like those big, huge, fun Hollywood tentpole movies as well because you did a bunch of them. You'd like to do one of those again.
就像那些拍起来很有趣。我是说，我会。我喜欢广泛的大众吸引力，这是我所支持的一切，因为我有三个孩子，16岁、18岁和20岁。哇。这么多选择，我承认有一点个人虚荣心想给他们留下深刻印象，但他们是孩子，我了解到他们喜欢，不，我想看《恐龙战队》。你真无聊。
Like those are fun to do. I mean, I would. I like the broad mass appeal and it's everything I'm for because I have three kids, 16, 18 and 20. Wow. So many of these choices to I'll admit to some personal vanity to try and impress them, but they're kids and I learned that they like, no, I want to watch Power Rangers. You're boring.
是的。所以，你知道，那个泡沫破灭了。但重点是，我知道现在看那部电影的很多人都有了自己的孩子。它成为了他们个人神话的一部分，他们随身携带的文化。是的，它不可能比现在更早地给我留下深刻印象。而且，你知道，展望未来，只是为了回答你的问题，我想参与到它再次被搬上银幕的方式中。
Yeah. So, you know, that bubble got burst. But the point is I, I know that so many people who watch that film all have kids of their own now. And it becomes a part of their personal mythology, their culture that they bring with them. Yeah, I could not have been impressed upon me earlier more so than it is now. And, you know, and going forward, just to answer your question, I'd like to participate in however that gets put on the screen again.
如果它是《木乃伊》或其他什么，我想这是做我真正关心的事情，比如《鲸》，和做，你知道，具有广泛吸引力的事情之间的抛硬币，理想情况下两者都做，就像你，就像你正在做的那样。它奏效了。是的。而且你当时有点在做那个。而且你当时在做那个。你当时在做那个。
If it's a mummy or something else, I guess it's a toss up between doing something I really care about, like the whale and something that is, you know, has broad appeal and ideally do both as you, as you were, as you were doing. It worked. Yeah. And you were kind of doing that. And you were doing that. You were doing that.
是的。我记得你和伊恩·麦克莱恩拍了《众神与野兽》。太好了。伟大的电影。但罗伯特·德尼罗是这么说的。他不是以说，一个给我，三个给他们而闻名吗？一个给我，三个给他们。我不知道。
Yeah. I remember you did Gods and Monsters with Ian McKellen. So good. Great film. But Robert De Niro says that. Isn't he famous for saying, one for me, three for them. One for me, three for them. I don't know.
他因为很多事情而出名，肖恩。我是说，老实说。不，就是那样。那不是他出名的原因。是的。不，就是那样。他可能很有名地说过，但他不出名。你在看我吗？
He's kind of famous for a lot of things, Sean. I mean, let's be honest. No, that's it. That's not what he's famous for. Yeah. No, that's it. He may have famously said, but he's not famous. Are you looking at me?
你在跟我说话吗？你在跟我说话吗？你一定是在跟我说话。你在跟我说话吗？嘿，一点点，一点点，你知道，一点点。是的，好。好吧。记得一点点。是的，没关系。
Are you talking to me? Are you talking to me? You must be talking to me. Are you talking to me? Hey, a little bit, a little bit, you know, a little bit. Yeah, good. Well. Remember a little bit. Yeah, no good.
你们看过我的，你们看过我的德尼罗模仿吗？哦，你会给我们更多吗？是的。不，你知道，我不会做很多，但我可能会给你一点点，一点点。我们喜欢这里的廉价货，布兰登。我们确实喜欢。我们只是在这里玩得开心。我们是廉价货。
You guys have seen my, you guys have seen my De Niro, right? Oh, will you give us some more? Yeah. No, you know, I'm not going to do a lot, but I might give you a little bit, a little bit. We love the cheap stuff here, Brendan. We sure do. We're just having fun here. We're cheapies.
这是一个周四的早晨，我们正在尽力玩得开心。你的孩子，你的孩子有任何，呃，呃，我正要问同样的事情。我正要说同样的事情。是的。他们很有创造力。是的。是的。我最小的拿起了一把吉他，他可以认真地弹奏。
It's a Thursday morning and we're trying to do our best to have fun. Do your kids, your kids have any, uh, uh, I was going to ask the same thing. I was going to say the same thing. Yes. They're creative. Yeah. Yes. My, my, my youngest picked up a guitar and he can seriously shred.
我说，哇。而且他正在学习音乐理论。他才16岁。所以，哇。那是利兰。而且，嗯，霍尔顿我18岁的儿子肯定对表演感兴趣，他要去学习。我不想说他要去的大学的名字，但我真的为他感到非常兴奋。
I'm like, wow. And he is studying music theory. He's only 16. So, wow. That's Leland. And, um, hold in my 18 year old son is interested for sure in acting and he's going to study. I don't want to say the name of the university he's going to go to, but I'm really very excited for him.
他作为高中生提前被录取了，所以现在是快乐的日子。我最大的儿子是格里芬。他是个有特殊需要的孩子。他被评为自闭症谱系，他是他一直以来最好的自己。他只是把我们所有人聚在一起的爱的体现，真的只是让我理解了我们甚至跑来跑去追逐自己的尾巴做这些疯狂事情的原因。
He got an early acceptance as a high school senior, so it's happy days now. And my oldest son is, is Griffin. He's a special needs kid. He's rated on autism spectrum and he's the best version of himself that he ever always was. And he's just the manifestation of love that keeps us all together and really just gives me the understanding of the reason why we even run around chasing our tails doing this crazy stuff.
是的，阿门。现在，他们三个都在房子里和你在一起吗？你们都住在那上面吗？不。我是说，两个小的和他们的妈妈住在格林威治，嗯，他们总是到这里来。我有，我有洗衣证明，还有破碎的窗户。
Yeah. Amen. Now, are they all three in the house with you there? You guys all live up there? No. I mean, the two younger guys live in Greenwich with their mom and, um, they're always over here. I have, I have laundry to prove it and broken windows.
是的。是的。我很高兴我有两个女儿。男孩会让你忙个不停。对吧。哇。好吧，你知道吗？我有个朋友有三个女儿，他叫她们搏击俱乐部。
Yeah. Yeah. I'm so glad I got two girls. Boys will keep you busy. Right. Wow. Well, you know what? I had a friend who had three girls and he called them the fight club.
是的。是的。有一个年龄段，他们，他们，他们，他们真的学会了他们的乐器。我自己有三个男孩，布兰登，所以他们稍微小一点，呃，但是我们，这里每天早上都是个动物园。他们去过急诊室了吗？嗯，呃，哦天哪，可能有。是的。
Yeah. Yeah. There is, there is an age there where they, they, they, they really learn their instrument. I've got, I've got three boys myself, Brendan, so they're a little bit younger and, uh, but we're, it's a, it's a zoo here every morning. Have they taken to the emergency room yet? Well, uh, oh God, might have. Yeah.
是的。对。你有。哦天哪。哦是的。在我家里，我们得有一张打孔卡，你知道，买三送一，对吧？缝针。是的。
Yeah. Right. You have. Oh God. Oh yeah. In my family, we had to have a punch card, you know, three get one free, right? Stitches. Yeah.
对我来说只有一次，和，呃，和弗兰妮，但是，呃，是的，和男孩们在这里，这是，这是每年的。对。所以阿奇，阿奇·伊纳布尔，这个，这是很多，很多缝针，但是，但是我应该指出，他们两个都是告密者，我警告过他们。我警告过他们，因为每个人都知道。听听那个。好吧，我只是知道，他们知道告密者会挨缝针，而且，那，那是另一个
Just once for me with, uh, with Franny, but, uh, yeah, with boys out here, it's, it's annual. Right. So Archie, the Archie Enable, the, this is a lot of, a lot of stitches, but, but how I should be pointing out, they're both of them are snitches and I had warned them. I had warned them because everybody knows. Listen to that. Well, I just know, they know that snitches get stitches and that, that's a, that's another
你在朱丽叶学到的东西，对吧？好吧，布兰登也去过监狱。是的。而且我们总是说在加拿大，在多伦多的罗斯代尔长大。这又回到了肖恩的孩子，瑞奇在肿瘤切除后缝了针，放进罐子里，呃，但现在它，呃，它，它又发炎了，对吧？是的。
thing you learned at Juliette, right? Well, Brendan has also been to jail. Yeah. And we always said that in Canada, growing up in Rosedale in Toronto. And this comes all the way back around to Sean's kid, Ricky got stitches after the tumor came out, put in a jar and, uh, but now it's, uh, it's, it's flamed up again then, right? Yeah.
是的。好吧，而且它掉进去了，因为他和斯科蒂正在煮一大锅，呃，猪肉和豆子。对。而且它掉进去了。一大锅黏糊糊的猪肉和豆子。他踢了一脚，踢了一脚，当然。而且他们有，肖恩，你上次吃猪肉和豆子是什么时候，老实说。
Yeah. Well, and it, it's fell in because he and Scotty was cooking up a big pot of, uh, pork and beans. Right. And it fell in. A big, sloppy pot of pork and beans. He gave it a little kick, a little kick, sure. And they have, Sean, last time you had pork and beans, be honest.
我昨天午饭确实刚吃了烤猪肉三明治。那不算。我是说，一大锅豆子，然后你切一些热狗，呃，扔进去。那本周会发生。听起来多好？太好了。还有通心粉和奶酪。布兰登·弗雷泽，我们占用了你太多时间，但伙计们，这太有趣了，能
I literally just had barbecued pork sandwich yesterday for lunch. It doesn't count. I mean, a big pot of beans and then you slice up some hot dogs and, and toss them in. That'll happen this week. How good does that sound? So good. And mac and cheese. Brendan Fraser, we have taken up way too much of your time, but guys, it's so fun getting
了解你，而且，而且它，它太。非常为你高兴，伙计。看到你真是太棒的故事了，祝贺你在电影中取得的所有成功，以及所有的提名。奥斯卡奖，英国电影学院奖，一切。最棒的是，你看起来一模一样。而且你看起来确实和你20年前一模一样。你看起来棒极了。
to know you and, and it's, it's so. Very happy for you, man. It's really such a great story to, to see you and congratulations on all the success you've had with this film and the nominations through the roof for everything. Academy award, BAFTA, everything. And the best of all, you look exactly the same. And you do look exactly the same as you did 20 years ago. You look terrific.
你对生活有很好的看法，能有你真是太高兴了，伙计。谢谢伙计们。是的。是的。我很高兴成为你的客人。谢谢。而且哦，等等。还有威尔，我只是想告诉你。
You got a great outlook on life and it's just what a joy to have you, man. Thanks guys. Yeah. Yeah. I'm really happy to be your guest. Thank you. And oh, wait. And Will, I just want to tell you.
你的笔记来了。当霍尔顿大概六七岁的时候，我想是《乐高蝙蝠侠大电影》在放，他非常喜欢它。他会引用你，当你，作为蝙蝠侠说，他不穿黑色，只是深色调的只是灰色调。那是怎么回事，你记得吗？我只穿黑色，有时，有时灰色。我想那是引用，非常深的灰色调，你知道吗？
Here comes your note. When Holden was like probably six or seven years old, I think it was in the Lego Batman movie, was on and he loved it so much. And he would quote you when you, as Batman said, that he doesn't wear black, just dark shades of just shades of gray. How is, do you remember that? I only work in black and sometimes, sometimes gray. I think that's what the quote, very dark shades of gray, you know what?
很有趣，那，那，那你说那个很有趣，布兰登。所以今天早上，四个男孩都在吃早餐，因为我有三个儿子和一个继子，他们正在吃早餐，丹尼，我两岁半的孩子，他正在用杯子喝牛奶。上面有超人，他看着它，他抬头看着我，说，那是你爸爸。我说，不，不，那是超人。我没得到那个。
It's funny that, that, that it's funny you say that, Brandon. So this morning, all four boys were having breakfast cause I have three sons and a step son and they're having breakfast and Denny, my two and a half year old, he's drinking his milk out of a cup. It's got Superman on it and he looks at it and he looks up at me and goes, that you data. And I go, no, no, that's Superman. I didn't get that one.
不过有三个回调。是的。相当不错。听着，伙计，再次，真是荣幸。请代我向你的儿子问好，来自乐高蝙蝠侠，我们会，我们，我们会见到你的。我确定我不知道这什么时候播出，但我，我，提前，希望祝贺你获得奥斯卡。是的。
Three callbacks though. Yeah. It was pretty good. Listen, dude, again, what a pleasure. Please say, say hi to your son for me from Lego Batman and we'll, we'll, we'll see you. I'm sure I don't know when this airs, but I, I, and early, hopefully congratulations on the Oscar. Yes.
阿门。阿门。谢谢。好吧，伙计。谢谢伙计。你也是。谢谢伙计。你也是。
Amen. Amen. Thank you. All right, pal. Thanks pal. You too. Thanks pal. You too.
谢谢。再见，布兰登。再见，伙计。多棒啊。什么，你知道，你说了威尔。那里有个故事，而且，你知道，这个世界上和这个行业里有太多的坏故事，那是一个真正的好消息。它确实是。
Thanks. Bye, Brandon. Bye, buddy. How great. What, you know, you said it will. There's a story there and, you know, it's, there's too many bad stories in this world and in this business that is, that is a real piece of good news right there. It really is.
而且就像它是一个故事，就像如果你，你知道，对于演员，无论你在职业生涯的哪个阶段，如果，如果这是你热爱做的事情，而且它不一定是表演，你只是继续做它。它不像你来来去去，一切都有涨落，除了中餐，你知道，只是因为它好吃并不意味着你需要吃完它。哦，肖恩那天确实去了。他回到，他告诉我这个。我发现了一家开着的Chin Chin。
And also like it's such a story, like if you, you know, for actors, wherever you are in your career, if, if it's the thing you love to do and it just doesn't have to be acting, you just keep doing it. It doesn't like you come and go, everything abs and flows and accept with Chinese food, you know, just because it tastes good doesn't mean you need to finish it. Oh, Sean did go the other day though. He went back to, he told me about this. I found a chin chin that was open.
记得吗，我以为它关门了。你不需要发短信告诉我们。好吧。我们没有，我们没有想知道。嘿，日落大道的Chin Chin还在营业。我说，是的。我不知道。知道了。
Remember, I thought it was closed. You don't need to text us with that. Okay. We weren't, we weren't wondering. Hey, the chin chin on Sunset's still open. I'm like, yeah. I didn't know. Got it.
记住，我以为它关门了。你不需要发短信告诉我们这个。好吧。我们并没有，我们并没有在想这件事。嘿，日落大道上的Chin Chin还在营业。我就说，是啊。我不知道。知道了。
Are you angry because you're jealous? Yeah. No, but it was the same reaction of like the toothless old prospector who's like in the river all day. I found one, there's no, you know what I mean? I'm so happy I texted you both. In the toothless community, don't come after me for that, but I just, they're pretty big. But listen, you know, look, I, again, I don't know when this is going to air, but I'm sure
你是因为嫉妒才生气吗？是啊。不，但这就像那个整天在河里淘金的没牙老矿工的反应一样。我找到了一个，没有，你明白我的意思吗？我很高兴给你们俩发了短信。在没牙的群体里，别因为这个来找我麻烦，但我只是觉得，它们相当大。但听着，你知道，看，我，再说一次，我不知道这什么时候播出，但我肯定
the Oscar goes too, right? I mean, I think so. That performance is incredible. He'll have a very good seat at a minimum there at the ceremony. It is. It is true. I used to see a guy who's seeming like such a nice guy and Sean, I agree with you. It's that he has kind of just continued to do what he does and be himself and blah, blah,
奥斯卡奖会颁给谁，对吧？我是说，我想是这样。那场表演太不可思议了。至少在颁奖典礼上，他会有一个非常好的座位。确实如此。确实如此。我过去常看到一个看起来人很好的人，肖恩，我同意你的看法。他只是继续做他所做的事，做他自己，等等，等等，
blah. And sometimes, sometimes the, the stars align and the world catches up with you and sometimes it doesn't. You just keep going. And then you just keep going. Remember John Travolta when Quentin Tarantino put him in Pulp Fiction was like, great, welcome. Yeah. Well, that's why I wanted to say it.
等等。有时，有时时机成熟，世界赶上了你，有时则不然。你只是继续前进。然后你只是继续前进。还记得昆汀·塔伦蒂诺让约翰·特拉沃尔塔出演《低俗小说》时，就像是，太棒了，欢迎回来。是的。嗯，这就是我想说的。
Because I hate calling it a comeback because, because in John Travolta's case too, he must have been like, I'm still the same guy. Right. It's just, they got another opportunity at a very high profile process. Yeah. It's just a high, yeah. It's just matters how high. And then every once, so that happens, or if you're an actor and it's not working out,
因为我讨厌称之为“卷土重来”，因为，因为在约翰·特拉沃尔塔的例子中，他一定觉得，我还是同一个人。对吧。只是他们得到了另一个非常高调的机会。是的。这只是一个高，是的。这只是取决于高度。然后每隔一段时间，这种情况就会发生，或者如果你是一名演员，而事情进展不顺利，
you move towards directing because people aren't responding and you're acting anymore. Right. That's a shot. That's a shot of me shot. Here he comes. Here he comes. Because people watch you, they're like, no, enough, we can't see it any more. We can't see it any more.
你就会转向导演，因为人们不再对你的表演有反应了。对吧。那是针对我的。那是针对我的。他来了。他来了。因为人们看着你，他们会说，不，够了，我们再也看不下去了。我们再也看不下去了。
Get behind the camera now. Wait, Will, when you guys were talking about the places you were in, in Canada, could you get, could you get there like by driving or like walking or is there like, could you, like, is there another way you get there? Don't go high. Don't go high. By riding a. Bye.
现在去摄像机后面吧。等等，威尔，当你们谈论在加拿大的那些地方时，你们能开车去那里，还是走路去，或者有其他方式去那里吗？别太高调。别太高调。骑着。再见。
Will's gone high. Will's gone high. You can't do it without going high, right? A piece of gold. Or maybe by a biplane. Or. I was a nice fizzle. You're really good.
威尔太高调了。威尔太高调了。你不高调就做不到，对吧？一块金子。或者也许乘双翼飞机。或者。我刚才那一下很精彩。你真的很棒。
Hand music rams. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Robotic. Manic.
手工音乐公羊。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。机器人般的。狂躁的。
And artisanally hand-crafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armijarv and Bennett Barbicco. Smart. Loss. Our next episode will be out in a week, wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now. Early on Amazon music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple podcasts or the Wondry app. Life is short, and it's full of a lot of interesting questions.
由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗伯·阿米贾夫和贝内特·巴比科手工制作。聪明。损失。我们的下一集将在下周播出，无论你在哪里收听播客，或者你现在就可以收听。在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过在苹果播客或Wondry应用程序上订阅Wondry Plus提前收听且无广告。生命是短暂的，充满了许多有趣的问题。
What does happiness really mean? How do I get the most out of my time here on earth? What really is the best cereal? These are the questions I seek to resolve on my weekly podcast, Life is Short with Justin Long. If you're looking for the answer to deep philosophical questions like, what is the meaning of life? I can't really help you. But I do believe that we really enrich our experience here by learning from others.
幸福到底意味着什么？我怎样才能充分利用我在地球上的时间？什么才是最好的麦片？这些是我在每周播客《人生苦短，贾斯汀·朗主持》中寻求解决的问题。如果你正在寻找像“生命的意义是什么？”这样深刻哲学问题的答案，我真的帮不了你。但我确实相信，通过向他人学习，我们真正丰富了我们在这里的体验。
And that's why in each episode I like to talk with actors, musicians, artists, scientists, and many more types of people about how they get the most out of life. We explore how they felt during the highs, and sometimes more importantly, the lows of their careers. We discuss how they've been able to stay happy during some of the harder times. But if I'm being honest, it's mostly just fun chats between friends about the important stuff like, if you had a sandwich named after you, what would be on it? So Life is Short wherever you get your podcasts.
这就是为什么在每一集中，我都喜欢与演员、音乐家、艺术家、科学家和更多类型的人交谈，探讨他们如何充分利用生活。我们探讨他们在职业生涯的高峰期，有时更重要的是，在低谷期的感受。我们讨论他们如何在一些困难时期保持快乐。但如果我诚实地说，这大多只是朋友之间关于重要事情的有趣聊天，比如，如果你有一个以你名字命名的三明治，里面会放什么？所以，无论你在哪里收听播客，请收听《人生苦短》。
You can also listen ad-free on the Amazon Music or Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你也可以在亚马逊音乐或Wondery应用程序上无广告收听。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。